welcome back to cbs this morning where
our colleagues at 48 hours have an
update to a story we first told you
about more than two years ago
involving two separate cases of missouri
inmates serving
extremely long prison sentences for
armed robbery
patrick flaherty and bobby bostic have
been behind bars for more than two
decades
trying to turn their lives around 48
hours correspondent aaron moriarty
takes us back to missouri for an
unlikely and emotional reunion
patrick flaherty never gave up hope that
someday he would see his mother again
as a free man oh we can go home
this day seemed all but impossible just
two years ago
when we first met flaherty at the
jefferson city correctional center in
missouri
where he has spent much of the past two
decades
flaherty was 22 years old in 1999
when he robbed four convenience stores
armed with an unloaded bb
gun it's a bb gun but it looks like the
real thing doesn't it
yes sir flaherty thought he'd get a 10
year sentence
and he did for each store and the judge
ordered the sentences to run
consecutively
when you hear the word consecutive
consecutive consecutive
and you start thinking your mind my god
that's
40 years in missouri inmates have to
serve 85 percent of a prison sentence
before they can even request parole it
was a life sentence for his mother
margaret too
you know i'm in my 70s now
i used to walk out after i visit him in
tears
because i never knew if i would be able
to see him again
flaherty spent his time going to school
earning degrees and certificates
even learning how to translate textbooks
into braille
but none of it bringing him any closer
to release
so we began to write letters thousands
of them
gaining a passionate group of supporters
who convinced missouri governor mike
parson
the flaherty now 44 years old deserved a
second chance
and last friday flaherty was finally
released into the arms of his mom and
stepfather
does that give you hope it gave me a lot
of hope in a place like this
all you got is hope that's what you hold
on to hope that you're going to get out
one day
if flaherty's 40-year sentence for
robbery seems excessive
consider bobby bostick he was 16
in 1995 when he and a friend committed
an armed robbery and a carjacking at
christmas time
boss 638 firearm was real and one of his
victims was grazed by a bullet
did you intend to hurt him to kill him
no if i had tend to her to kill him i'd
have kept shooting
but i didn't tend to hurt him off shoot
he's just i was in my young mind
it's no excuse when i look back it's no
excuse for what i did
but bostick a juvenile never expected
the judge to rule so
harshly i didn't think i'd get 30. and
how many years did you get 241 years
did you think he was irredeemable
yes at the time judge evelyn baker now
retired
thought the sentence was appropriate for
bostick i didn't expect him to survive
prison
i figured with this behavior she was
going to wind up dead
but instead when he had money bostick
spent it on college classes
and the teen who never read a book wrote
15
behind bars and he has held on to hope
even when he watches those with murder
convictions
go home ahead of him got something to
give to the world
so i got to act on that hope i got to
just keep
going even when this appeal get denied i
got to keep going because one day
something happened and remarkably the
person
who most wants to see that happen 241
years is insanity
when i think back on it and i'll say
right now it's insanity
he was a kid he was a little boy but
you're the one who sentenced him judge
yes as he evolved i have evolved
i mean is it fair to say that the case
of bobby bostic
has haunted you that would be a very
true statement
i don't want to go to my grave with
bobby incarcerated
i think bobby has so much that he can
give to this world
do you think that someday bobby bosick
will be walking out the same door
100 i think i think next year
well there is hope for bobby bostic
there is a new bill sitting on missouri
governor parsons desk
waiting for a signature which will give
bosek and others who were sentences
sentenced as juveniles the ability to
petition the parole board
for a hearing but that is no guarantee
that basic will be released
he is a lot closer i do want to point
out under this very complicated formula
if the governor does not sign that bill
basic is eligible
for parole wait for it when he's 112
years old i know aaron you hear that
story and you you have to wonder why he
is not out today
yes that somebody looking at this story
hopefully will step in this makes no
sense to me well this is why the judge
is speaking out
um she actually even helped him petition
the supreme court in 2017.
is there more she can or should do no
it's very interesting i think people are
surprised to hear that judges can't do a
do-over yeah exactly
the judge could say i made a mistake i'm
changing this ruling but she is coming
out she's even visited him in prison
and she feels very strongly these guys
are forgotten
which is why i just wonder how she came
up with the 241 years in the first
place well there were 17 counts and then
he was
you know convicted of all and then she
made them consecutive
and that's why it's but the judge has
discretion in those cases
exactly you can believe in justice and
not want to throw away a child a 16 year
old
but he didn't look like he had remorse
that's what she thought at the time
you heard her say she thought he was
gonna die in prison exactly but as she
says as he has evolved
i have evolved i'm glad she said that
but bobby needs to be out today
thank you aaron